the total number of valid second
preference votes
cast for each of the remaining
candidates is as follows
street andrew john the conservative
party candidate
15 hundred and fifty one
burn liam labour and cooperative party
twenty three thousand six hundred and
seventeen
the total number of ballot papers
rejected at the second count is as
follows
7568
want of official mark zero voting for
more than one candidate as to the second
preference vote
114 writing or mark by which voters
could be identified
one unmarked as the second preference
vote
7299 void for uncertainty as to the
second preference vote
154. so the total of valid first
and second preference votes for each of
the remaining candidates
is as follows street
andrew john the conservative party
candidate
first preference is 299 thousand
three hundred and eighteen second
preferences
fifteen thousand three hundred and fifty
one
total three hundred and fourteen
thousand six hundred and sixty nine
burn liam labor and cooperative party
first preferences two hundred and forty
four thousand
and nine second preferences
twenty three thousand six hundred and
seventeen
total two hundred and sixty seven
thousand
six hundred and twenty six
so i declare that street andrew john
the conservative party candidate is duly
elected
as mayor for the west midlands combined
authority